- I've heard that you
speak about co-parenting
and I'm doing that right now, too.
It's tough.
Is it harder than you thought?
Is it working with you and Tristan?
I know with me and Brandon,
it's just a difficult thing
'cause we're in different places
and it's like we both
agree on the main things,
but it's a hard thing
when you're not together
all the time, for me personally.
Has it been hard for you?
- My parents were the most perfect example
and I was really blessed
and fortunate to have that
as my example, and to see
that, and even with my stepdad
and the integration of all of that
and how my dad and my stepdad
dealt with one another
was really just such a
beautiful thing to witness.
They played golf once a week and I'm sure
that wasn't easy for my
dad, but he did it for us.
And so, having that
really selfless example
was awesome for us.
So, I think, with all of
us, whether it be Kourtney
and Scott or Tristan and
myself, we definitely,
I try to mirror that and
always keep it about the kids,
but with Tristan, it's a trust thing
and Tristan is so great and
really trust me as a mom
and knows I'm always gonna
do the right thing for True.
So, he really doesn't tell
me no, a lot of the times
and I'm grateful for that
because I think, as moms,
we just sort of feel like
we have the right to,
we know what we're doing with our kids.
But it was funny, the other day I wanted,
True is gonna be three in April,
and I wanted to give
her her very first trim
and when I mean trim, like
not even half an inch,
I just wanted to cut
some of her baby hairs
and Tristan, I don't
think has ever told me no,
and he really freaked out by
me wanting to cut her hair.
And I just, it was so crazy
to me how he was freaking out.
He called my brother for my
brother to talk me out of it.
He called my mom.
I was like, "Oh my God, I
wasn't gonna give her a trim
"if you," I didn't know he
was that adamant about it,
until everybody else started calling me,
but I didn't do it 'cause I
also have to show him that I,
"Okay, if you don't
want me to do something
"that badly, I'm not gonna do it."
So it's just, I think,
great with communication
and trust is the most important thing,
I think, with raising kids.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I think you're right, too.
That's what Brandon and
I are focusing on, too,
it's like as long as you make
sure it's about the children
and their best interest,
then we're both on board.